الاسرائيلي. هل يكون بوتين هو
بطرس الاكبر الثاني في تاريخ
بسبب زيادة اسعار الطاقة.
اليونان تتهم تركيا بمحاولة فرض
مطار دمشق الدولي سيظل خارج
الخدمة حتى اشعار اخر بسبب
البلطيق خلال الحرب الباردة كانت
كلنجراد رأس الحربة السوفيتي في
جارديان البريطانية ان المعركة
مع روسيا الان معركة دفاعية وان
الكثير من القدرات الروسية لم
تستخدم بعد في رسالة مباشرة
الساحة هو فقط خمسة بالمائة من
السلاح الروسي رغم توالي
دولة وهي المناورة التي قالت
عنها اليونان انها تجرى ضدنا.
مواجهة قوات الناتو في بحر
البلطيق باكمله. وسط مخاوف غربية
الروسي واعتقد انها مبالغة.
البنتاجون يرسل سلاح الخارق
ها هي استراليا تعلن عبر رئيس
وزرائها انتوني المانيس انها
بموجبها خمسمائة وخمسة وخمسين
مليون يورو كتعويضات ويأتي ذلك
تسليح جزر بحر ايجا وردا على
الاستفزازات اليونانية. وبحضور
توصلت الى تسوية عادلة ومنصفة مع
مجموعة نافال الفرنسية بشأن
من اوروبا. بعد خيانة استراليا
لفرنسا وتخلفها عن صفقة بخمسة
قرارها العام الماضي بالغاء صفقة
الغواصات الفرنسية وستدفع
نشرت وزارة النقل في حكومة
النظام السوري بيانا قالت فيه ان
وخمسين مليار يورو مقابل عقد
صفقة اخرى مع امريكا وبريطانيا.
بعد توتر العلاقات بين فرنسا
واستراليا بعد هذه الخيانة.
التقارب مع العرب واسرائيل فهل
يفعلها العرب ويتقربون من الد
الرئيس اردوجان اختتمت اكبر
مناورات عسكرية اي اف اي اس
روسيا? الجزائر تقطع العلاقات مع
الاسبان في حين الغرب الى
الاضرار الكبيرة التي تعرض لها
في اكثر من موقع جراء القصف
الروسي سيدمر الاوروبي الذي
يعاني بالفعل من ارتفاع التضخم
والغرب. منطقة كالينجراد في اقصى
الغرب الروسي محطة صراع بارد
الفين واثنين وعشرين في ولاية
ازمير غربي تركيا سبع وثلاثين
يؤججه انضمام فنلندا والسويد الى
الناتو. كالينجراد منطقة واقعة
الخطوط الامامية هي التي ستقرر
المستقبل. تم نقل اكثر من الف
بوتين الجغرافي لتهديد اوروبا
واكثر النقاط سخونة بين روسيا
التعثرات وزيادة الخسائر
العسكرية لمغامرة الحرب في
سنوات منذ توقيعه. بل يكون العرب
درعا لاسرائيل. وهل يستطيع
الغاز الطبيعي منهما فيما اشارت
الوثيقة الى ان العقد سيمتد لتسع
بايدن يقول ان زيلنسكي لم يرغب
في سماع التحذيرات بشأن الهجوم
قال نائب رئيس الاستخبارات
العسكرية الاوكرانية لصحيفة
الغربية من خطورة المنطقة.
الاحداث والتطورات. ما ترونه في
جندي اوكراني اسير الى روسيا
للتحقيق معهم. هنجاريا حظر الغاز
اسرائيل من استخراج الغاز من حقل
كريش. سلاح الجغرافيا. سلاح
امر واقع وتغيير الوضع شرقي
المتوسط. واردوغان يرد ويحذر من
الجمهوريات الروسية. ويرسو فيها
الاسطول العسكري للكرملين في
للغرب وامريكا. يجب اتخاذ خطوات
تاريخية كي تصبح اوكرانيا جزءا
اقترحت على الدول الاعضاء تمويل
عقد صفقة مع مصر واسرائيل لشراء
منظومة الدفاعية الى اوكرانيا
شريطة عدم ضرب الاراضي الروسية.
هذا كله في حين اتى الرد من
لبنان على استفزازات تل ابيب
الامين العام لحزب الله اللبناني
حسن نصر الله قادرون على منع
فالى متى سيستمر ابناء زايد في
خيانة اشقائهم في فلسطين. فيما
الفراعنة تعويض الغاز الروسي اي
صف سيختار العرب يا ترى? ياتي
اوكرانيا. محللون عسكريون بحسب
مجلة فورين بوليسي يقولون ان
طرح اعضاء في الكونجرس الامريكي
مشروع قانون يقضي بان تسعى وزارة
لتوينيا وبولندا على بحر
البلطيق. لا تربطها حدود مشتركة
من نشر صواريخ اسكندر ومنظومة اس
اربعمائة فيها. الجيش الروسي نفذ
بينما اختتم زيارته لدبي باتفاق
لنشر منظومة رادارية في مناطق
فيها تدريبات لاطلاق صواريخ
نووية وهو ما عزز المخاوف
ودول عربية. وقالت وثيقة حصلت
عليها ان المفوضية الاوروبية
بالشرق الاوسط بما فيها والبحرين
ضمن رؤية للتعاون المشترك في
بالمناطق الروسية الاخرى خالية
من الجليد على النقيض من بقية
الدولتين. كانت تدعو الجانبين
الى السيطرة على تدفقات الهجرة
عمليات التجارة الخارجية مع
اسبانيا بعد ساعات من معاهدة
الامريكية على التخلي الفوري عن
خطتها لبيع الاسلحة الى تايوان
الصداقة وحسن الجوار معها بسبب
موقف مدريد المفاجئ من قضية
الدفاع الامريكية البنتاجون الى
دمج الدفاعات الجوية لاسرائيل
مواجهة تهديدات ايران الصاروخية
وخلق منظومة للانذار المبكر.
مختلفة. اسبانيا ابدت اسفها على
الجزائر واكدت التزامها بمضمون
ومبادئ المعاهدة المبرمة في
الفين واثنين مع الجزائريين على
الغرب والاعداء الا يمزحوا هكذا
تعلنها الجزائر للعالم. العرب
وصلت رسائل بكين ايها الامريكان؟
بالمقابل قال وزير الدفاع
مع نظيره الامريكي اذا تجرأ اي
شخص على فصل تايوان عن الصين.
ووقف العلاقات العسكرية بين
الطرفين. وقال ويفان خلال لقاء
واسرائيل. وجود مريب لرئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي في الامارات
خطوات اضافية حيال تايوان تزعزع
الاستقرار. الجزائر لا تمزح. بعد
ان قطعت كل علاقاتها مع الكيان
الصهيوني الجزائر تجمد اليوم
الصحراء الغربية واعلانها دعم
مشروع الحكم الذاتي الذي تقترحه
فلن يتردد الجيش الصيني بكل
تأكيد في بدء حرب مهما كلف فهل
الامريكي لنظيره الصيني ان على
الصين الامتناع عن القيام باي
لهذه الغازات. من جانب اخر قال
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ان
بلاده تحاول الان استعادة
اراضيها الاصلية تماما كما فعل
ومحاكمة التجار بالبشر وتطوير
التعاون بين البلدين بمجالات
التنين الصيني. اعتبر وزير
الدفاع الصيني وي فينج ان توريد
الصينية الداخلية وحث الوزير
الصيني الولايات المتحدة
حاكم بطرس الاكبر حين شن حرب
الشمال لمدة واحد وعشرين عاما.
على الوقوف امام دب روسيا في
طريقها لاستعادة اراضيها? رسائل
المضادة. امريكا تقطع الرقائق
الالكترونية عن روسيا وهنا يأتي
المغرب مجلس الامن الجزائري الغى
معاهدة عمرها عشرين عاما بين
ويبدو ان هناك اعتقادا بانه قاتل
مع السويد واستولى على شيء ما
الاسلحة من الولايات المتحدة الى
تايوان. تدخل صارخ في الشؤون
لاسبانيا وتقطع العلاقات معها عن
اي عزة وشموخ نتحدث. واستراليا
ضد ايران فهل يقبل العرب بتحالف
كهذا مع كيان محتل؟ تركيا ترد
ما يراه الغرب ليس الا قطرة من
البحر المظلم لاسلحة روسيا
بقطع الغازات النبيلة. فهل
تعادلت الكفتان الان الكريملين
وذلك ردا على قيود فرضتها وزارة
الخزانة الامريكية على تصدير
تقبل باريس بذلك؟ فيما تحاول
امريكا لم شمل اسرائيل مع العرب
تعوض خيانتها لفرنسا بملايين
الدولارات عوضا عن عشرات فهل
على اليونان عسكريا والوضع يزداد
حدة وتوترا بينهما. العقوبات
الجزائر تظهر القوة مرة اخرى
وبعد اسرائيل هي تقول كفى
الرقائق الالكترونية الى روسيا
وتعتبر روسيا من اكبر الموردين
فرض قيود على تصدير الغازات
النبيلة الى الدول غير الصديقة
منها لكنه لم يستول على شيء فهو
استعاد الارض فقط. فهل تجرؤ دولة
الم تعلموا ما فعله بطرس الاكبر؟
حسنا ستعلمونه عندما نستعيد
الرد الروسي حاسما وقويا اعلنت
وزارة التجارة الروسية قبل ايام
بسلاحها الجغرافي وتكبل اقدامه.
روسيا ترد على عقوبات امريكا
اراضينا الاصلي. هكذا قالها
بوتين. موسكو تحاصر حلف الناتو
اعدائهم?
وقواتها. الامارات فلسطين للمرة
الثالثة على التوالي والصين
تقولها امام الامريكان سنحارب
ونسحق كل من يتدخل في تايوان.